Recuerdo cómo de niño
solía hacerme cargo de la cena y ordenar comida para todos.
Partir el pan me ha permitido partir el molde
y conectar con la gente.
Mi colega Les y yo
crecimos en la misma calle del Bronx,
dos tíos callejeros.
Él logró convertirse en chef.
Siempre hablábamos de hacer algo relacionado con la comida
que beneficiase al barrio.
Les acaba de ganar en el en el programa de TV "Trinchado".
Nuestro colega Malcom se prepara para llevar la pastelería del Noma,
sí, ese Noma, el mejor restaurante del mundo, en Copenhage.
Mi amigo P acaba de terminar su formación en Italia,
en Milan, para ser más exactos.
Decidimos que el mundo necesitaba algo de condimento del Bronx,
así que nos juntamos y creamos Ghetto Gastro.
(Aplausos)
Aunque sé que nuestro nombre hace sentir incómodos a muchos,
para nosotros "gueto" significa casa.
Del mismo modo que alguien en Bombay o Nairobi
puede que use la palabra "chabola",
es para ubicar a nuestra gente
y para condenar el sistema negligente que creó estas condiciones.
(Aplausos)
Y, ¿qué es Ghetto Gastro?
Básicamente es un movimiento y una filosofía.
Vemos el trabajo que hacemos como gastro-diplomacia,
usando la comida y la delicadeza
para abrir las fronteras y conectar culturas.
El año pasado, en Tokio,
hicimos una hamburguesa caribeña,
hacemos ternera de wagyu salteada,
shio kombu.
Mezclamos lo clásico del Bronx con elementos japoneses.
Y para la fiesta de Kwanzaa,
rendimos homenaje a nuestros puertorriqueños,
e hicimos unos coquitos de coco al carbón y coñac. Dímelo!
(Risas)
Este de aquí es nuestro waffle Black Power,
con sirope dorado.
Asegúrense de no babear las butacas.
(Risas)
Aquí tenemos el Velato a base de plantas a 36 grados Brix.
Campos de fresas, ya saben el rollo.
Sandía comprimida,
semillas de albahaca,
algunas fresas por encima.
Volviendo a la Bronx Brasserie,
ya saben, allí tenemos que tirarles a la cabeza el pan de maíz con caviar.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
También practicamos la diplomacia Du-rag.
(Risas)
Porque no cambiamos de apariencia mientras hacemos lo nuestro.
Debido a nuestro aspecto,
muchas veces nos confunden con raperos o deportistas.
Ocurrió aquí en TED el año pasado.
Este tipo se me acercó
y me preguntó cuando iba a actuar.
¿Qué te parece ahora?
(Aplausos)
Así que ya ven,
hemos estado acercando el Bronx al mundo
pero ahora estamos centrados en llevar el mundo al Bronx.
Hemos apenas abierto nuestro sitio,
una cocina de ideas,
donde hacemos y diseñamos productos,
creamos contenido,
(Música)
y acogemos eventos sociales.
La intención es generar capital financiero
y capital creativo en nuestro barrio.
También colaboramos con el renombrado chef
Massimo Bottura
en un refettorio en el Bronx.
Un refectorio es un centro comunitario y comedor social de diseño.
Ya ven la onda.
(Aplausos)
La reciente efusión de dolor debido a la muerte
del rapero y empresario Nipsey Hussle
se debe principalmente a que él decidió quedarse y desarrollarse
en el barrio en lugar de irse.
Ahora que está muerto, algunos pueden ver su decisión como errada,
pero yo tomo la misma decisión cada día:
vivir en el Bronx,
crear en el Bronx,
invertir en el Bronx.
(Aplausos)
En Ghetto Gastro no huimos de la palabra "gueto",
y no huimos del gueto.
Porque al final del día,
Ghetto Gastro es para mostrarles lo que nosotros ya conocemos:
que el barrio
es bueno.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.